please donate to give directly the
non-profit letting you send cash
directly to the world's poorest families
when you donate to give directly.org
Pacman a generous donor will match your
donations up to fifteen thousand dollars
makes a perfect holiday gift help us
reach fifteen thousand dollars by the
end of the year using the link below
let's start today with the Twitter files
there's a growing story being told by
those on the right in the Maga crowd and
elsewhere that the left whoever that is
supposed to mean is quote ignoring the
Twitter files which some are calling
orwellian and one of the greatest
stories about censorship and uh
Injustice towards right-wing
perspectives in decades or something and
I want to go through this and really
break it down into its component parts
the first question is whether the left
and let's pretend we know exactly what
they mean by that the left is ignoring
it that is absolutely untrue and in fact
you can I can I can really only speak
for myself and others that I am I'm sort
of aware of but we've all been talking
about it and you can find numerous
stories about the Twitter files on my
YouTube channel and our podcast archives
Etc now invariably
the people who first say David you've
been ignoring it will see the things
I've said and they said well you're
ignoring the main point which is that
Twitter and Biden and big Tech censor
the right and then also try to help the
left by preventing negative story well
so it's not that I'm ignoring it it's
that you don't like the conclusion I've
come to so let's talk about the reality
of the Twitter files if you are media
literate and internet literate and you
look at this story
and you look at the facts you realize
there is practically nothing there now I
won't say nothing there I I say
practically nothing there and we'll get
to what there is there but this Twitter
file story
is fundamentally a grievance Story the
type of grieving story that the right
loves to say the left is obsessed with
the right loves to say the left is all
about grievance culture I've been
wronged because of my race and I've been
wronged because of my gender and I've
been wrong because you know whatever
fill in the blanks this is the story
that the right loves to tell and they
say the left's got to move on from
Grievances and get something done this
is a grieving story that's what this is
and it's a grieving story comprised of
out of context anecdotes to point to a
heavily biased conclusion supported by
incomplete data
at best and that's like the most
charitable analysis that I can give the
narrative that has been presented
doesn't actually align with the content
of the Twitter files and there's a
disconnect here that has left a lot of
people wondering why aren't the Twitter
files being treated as a bigger deal
there's a mainstream media blackout on
the Twitter files and left-wing media
you won't talk about it initially the
story about the Twitter files was
supposed to be government is censoring
big tech companies and big tech
companies are censoring the right and
helping the left eventually it was
revealed Twitter was making its own
decisions about content on its platform
which the right has previously defended
their right to do
as a private company and the government
by which they actually mean the Biden
Campaign which wasn't even the
government at the time
was uh calling to the attention of
Twitter content they believed violate
Twitter's violated Twitter's terms of
service which it did of nude images of
Hunter Biden now
another aspect to the story was the
Biden again they called it the Biden
Administration but it was it was 2020
there was no Biden Administration the
Biden Administration was forcing the
removal of content related to Hunter
Biden we later discovered that the Biden
team was initially just using the normal
methods to report content and later had
email contacts that they could use at
Twitter to say hey we believe this
violates your terms of service
importantly
the Trump campaign the Trump
Administration also had access to the
very same people at Twitter via email so
it was not unique to the Biden campaign
and at the end of the day with the Biden
team was asking to have removed was
content that was illegal in Most states
and violated Twitter's own terms of
service it's sometimes called revenge
porn I understand that that term is uh
problematic to some because porn makes
it sound like it's consensual these were
explicit and obscene I don't know what
type of explicit images uh that were
released without the consent of Hunter
Biden right that's what we're talking
about that's what this was fundamentally
about it deflated the entire story
the story was also supposed to be about
the Trump White House trying to demand
that content be removed
and that is largely being ignored the
people on the right that are saying the
story is about Hunter Biden exclusively
ignore that the Trump White House
Government and administration also had
the same access that the Biden campaign
had and they would ask for content to
remove and they're not talking about
that they want to ignore that part of it
because it doesn't fit the narrative
that they want you to believe and then
lastly we were told well the FBI is
telling Twitter what to censor
turns out that wasn't true turns out the
FBI shared information with Twitter
about potential sources of
disinformation and ultimately Twitter
made its own determinations now you
would say Well when the FBI comes to you
and says hey here's here's information
the FBI wants you to do something but as
the Twitter files have come out it
doesn't actually appear that that was
the case it appears that Twitter was
able to decide on its own genuinely
decide on its own what to remove and
what not to remove so the the
unfortunate part for the right is that
the Twitter files didn't live up to the
hype the Twitter files don't actually
confirm the initial narrative that was
presented to them instead they have
become sort of a cudgel for the right
and Elon Musk and Matt taibi and the
other people Bari Weiss to spin a story
and drive a narrative but the efforts
have largely failed they want to say
we presented the bombshell and it is a
bombshell and the left and mainstream
media won't talk about it because of
their bias the reality is they failed to
actually present the bombshell they
claim this to be so people are sort of
looking at it and saying oh there's not
really a very big story here and what
you will often find is that those who
claim it's a very big story when you
actually say to them which part is the
bombshell they go well the Biden
Administration was uh it was 2020 there
was no Biden Administration well they
were censoring the hunter but well we're
talking about explicit images released
without his consent they're illegal in
Most states and violate Twitter's terms
after okay well so and then there's
nothing left there's just nothing left
so the question really becomes how much
do you expect quote the left
to talk about a story that isn't
anywhere near what it was supposed to be
you've got people cherry-picking details
and spinning them to fit a narrative
that has largely Fallen apart and
downplaying the parts that are
inconvenient like the fact that the
actual Trump administration had the very
same access to Twitter terms of service
and content moderation people last thing
the Twitter files are part of a larger
puzzle it's a piece of a larger puzzle
and we shouldn't ascribe more
significance to the Twitter files in the
broader context of the story when we
talk about the state of media and
politics and speech and censorship and
all these different things there is a
big story there and it's about the
unmitigated spread of disinformation on
Facebook particularly among older folks
the use of Twitter by white nationality
there's there's tons of story there
really is a story there
but what the Twitter files is is a
little tiny piece of it that is out of
context and also being inaccurately
reported and so for the people that are
insisting that the Twitter files are one
of the greatest and most orwellian
stories of manipulation of the public
it's hyperbole it's sensationalism it's
not a fair and balanced approach to the
facts we should talk about and be aware
about media bias we should be aware of
propaganda manipulation censorship but
we've got to be critical and objective
and if you're critical and objective and
you actually look at the claims that
were initially made and what was
actually revealed by the Twitter files
you realize that there's very little
there what you could say and this is
when we get back to is there a
legitimate story
You could argue You could argue that
neither the Trump Administration nor the
Biden campaign
should have been able to email anyone at
Twitter to say we believe this violates
her terms of service you could make the
case
they should have to just use the report
feature like everybody else that's the
one thing you could argue but if you
want to argue that you have to apply it
not only to the Biden campaign but also
to the Trump White House and I'm not
seeing anybody do that
it is back folks the U.S will require
negative covid tests for travelers
coming from China after more than half
of a plane load of passengers from China
to Italy tested positive for covid
does it work to require incoming
travelers to test well we'll talk about
that in a moment NPR reports U.S will
require travelers from China to show
negative covet tests before flight
um this will apply to Travelers from
China Hong Kong and Macau to show a
negative covet test before entering the
United States the CDC announced the
measure yesterday it will go into effect
January 5 for all passengers over age
two passengers must show a negative PCR
or monitored antigen tests no more than
two days before departure whether it's a
direct flight or whether you're coming
from another country if you go China
London New York you would still have to
show such a test even though strictly
speaking your flight is coming into the
U.S from London the monitor test must be
overseen by a Telehealth service
CDC is pointing to the surge in coveted
cases in China and the quote lack of
adequate and transparent epidemiological
and viral genomic sequence data being
reported from that country quote reduced
testing and case reporting in China and
minimal sharing of viral genomic
sequence data could delay the
identification of new variants of
concern if they arise so there's a few
different things that I think are
important to talk about here and one of
the things that I want to just remind
people when it comes to transparency
from China if you look right now at the
official reports of
um data from China China since the start
of the panda we're talking three years
folks China is officially reporting that
they've had only 400 000 coveted cases
and only 5200 deaths you would have to
be living under a rock and suffering
from serious confusion to believe that
these numbers are even
remotely connected to the reality of
covet in China
another interesting thing if you look at
the official data China is starting to
report higher case numbers but never
more than 5 000 cases a day and yet they
have not officially reported any deaths
since May so it is absolutely correct
that the data we're getting from China
is bogus and if you look at just a
little anecdote the hill reports nearly
half of passengers from China to Milan
have covet look at this nearly half of
the passengers on two recent flights to
Milan from China tested positive 38
percent of passengers on one flight and
52 percent of those on a second flight
had coveted there is no way that the
entire country of China with a
population of is it 1.3 billion at this
point 1.4 billion people there's no way
they have only four or five thousand
cases a day
and no deaths if half of two random
flights from China to Italy are people
who have coveted okay so a hundred
percent it is correct to believe that
there is a crazy amount of covet coming
out of China now the question is does
requiring entry covet tests work you
know the idea is
you require people to test to come in
you identify people who should
immediately go into quarantine
and hopefully you prevent the spread yes
I mean the idea makes some sense the
difficulties are many uh the supervised
antigen tests remember when I was in
Spain Last Summer
uh my girlfriend that I did these
supervised antigen tests where it's just
a home test but someone watches you do
it and my girlfriend got two false
positives and she was negative we ended
up having to find a hospital on a Sunday
Catholic holiday in Spain which I can
tell you is very difficult to do get a
PCR turned out she was turned out she
was negative
um those tests are not the most accurate
but not only are false positives a
problem false negatives particularly in
asymptomatic people are a major major
problem in fact when I had covet a few
weeks ago I was testing negative on
those tests even though I had covid
until I don't even know I guess day
three of my symptoms so the limitations
are
um asymptomatic people often test
negative on those tests
um it's not a guarantee you're not
infected
the fact that you can get the test two
days before travel makes it particularly
unhelpful the incubation period of covid
even though you know if you look at the
bell curve most people start showing
symptoms uh between two to five days
after exposure it can be up to 10 or
even more days so is that a reason not
to do anything no but it is a reason why
the technique may not be that effective
to be perfectly Frank
the most effective part of requiring
testing for people coming from China is
it might dissuade people who are
carrying the virus from even coming to
the United States at all uh but the the
real effectiveness of that policy is a
question mark I think is the point
doesn't mean we shouldn't do anything
doesn't mean we shouldn't be concerned
but we have to be sort of realistic
about that uh about that strategy let me
know your thoughts let me know if your
perspective is changing on uh sort of
like your risk tolerance at this point
and of course you immediately will get
the debate over this will inevitably be
what happens in the United States
because it's happening now in China
versus it might not be China has a very
low level of immunity as a result of
their zero coveted policy and so it's
not necessarily the case that what we
see in China is going to happen in the
United States remains to be seen make
sure you're subscribed on YouTube
youtube.com the davidpackman show we're
going to take a quick break and be right
back with so much more to start winding
down 2022.
over this holiday season please remember
how many families around the world are
living in extreme poverty our partner
give directly is the non-profit letting
you send cash directly to the world's
poorest households help the David
packman show reach our goal of fifteen
thousand dollars by the end of the year
at give directly.org Pacman a generous
give directly donor will match all
donations up to fifteen thousand dollars
to help us hit that goal so your
donation can have double the impact
giving in someone's name is a great last
minute holiday gift when organizations
give cash to families like this about 90
cents on the dollar get to the recipient
versus sometimes as little as 50 cents
on the dollar in terms of relative
impact with many other programs that's
why I reached out to give directly about
doing this with us give directly is how
you know every dollar you donate is
going to good use giving even a few
dollars can have a massive impact for
someone living on a dollar or two a day
help us reach fifteen thousand dollars
by December Thirty One and your donation
will be doubled go to give directly.org
Pacman the link is down below I would
love for you yes you I'm really talking
to you to sign up on our website
joinpakman.com we do depend directly on
the support of our viewers and listeners
to do the show that we do and we do an
extra show every single day for our
members you can sign up at
joinpakman.com and not only get the
bonus show but also get commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
hours before anybody else gets them we
also have our next members only Town
Hall coming up soon I'll be making an
announcement about that and uh as a
member you will get exclusively invited
to participate and talk to me in that
town hall sign up at joinpakman.com
it'll take you and I mean with average
like computer skills it's probably 45 to
60 seconds to sign sign up and and quite
frankly it's probably no more than a
minute and a half even with mediocre
Tech skills so I encourage you to do it
you can use the coupon code 24 starts
now to get yourself a sizable discount
Republicans are now desperately
rethinking if and how they should be
talking about abortion during their
campaigns because of the disastrous flop
of the 2022 midterms remember that in
2022
historically speaking Republicans should
have done unbelievably well they should
have probably taken control of the
Senate which they did not they actually
lost ground in the Senate going from 50
to 49 seats they should have taken
control of the house with a much greater
margin but they did not and now
Republicans are in the situation of
having to rethink their strategy there's
an interesting Hill article by Julia
Manchester which says Republicans are
recalibrating their messaging on
abortion after Democrats successfully
used the issue to Galvanize their base
and win over swing voters in 2022 while
the GOP largely focused on the
three-pronged message of combating
rising inflation crime and the flow of
migrants over the Border exit polls
showed abortion was a top priority for
voters at The Ballot Box
Republican committee chair Ronald
McDaniel said quote it was probably a
bigger Factor than a lot of people
thought
we've got to get conversant on that we
can't just do an ostrich method and
pretend that it doesn't exist when
Democrats are spending 30 million
dollars on that message according to
exit polling 27 of Voters said abortion
was the most important issue coming in
only behind inflation at 31 so there's a
few things to understand here in general
abortion is a deeply polarizing issue
and so there's always a risk when you
campaign on either side of a really
polarizing issue that you're gonna
alienate a large swath of the electorate
that's just a general thing with
polarizing issues the issue in
particular with abortion for Republicans
is that not only is it polarizing but
the country continues to be more and
more and more in favor of abortion being
legal in most cases and in fact we've
we've seen a steady increase in the Roe
v Wade era which ended a few months ago
in Americans generally speaking saying
yeah in most cases this should be legal
and so when you take that away a as the
Supreme Court did as a right
and then Republicans can campaign on how
great that is it's not necessarily going
to be useful to you
secondly abortion is a distraction in a
sense to more pressing issues that
Americans feel that they are facing in
the sense that Republicans could be
focusing on the economy Healthcare
education for and foreign policy without
the drag of their position on abortion
being there and what I mean by that is
the following Republicans tried to make
their campaigns to a degree about
inflation and the border and Biden's bad
and whatever and we can adjudicate
whether that's a good or bad idea on its
own but they were dragged down by the
knowledge and the timing of the Roe v
Wade diverse reversal by the Supreme
Court and so many Republicans saying
that that was a really great thing and
so that was also a problem for
republicans and the the maybe last part
of this is of course I'm pro-choice you
all know that
but the American people are mostly
pro-choice and so the Republican
position on abortion with some
Republicans saying there should be some
exceptions but putting that aside it's a
flawed and misguided ideology and as I
mentioned before
the position of Republicans is based on
the assumption that abortion is morally
wrong it should be banned it should be
illegal maybe it's murder in many cases
regardless of the situation or the
circumstances it ignores the reality
that most Americans don't see it that
way and of course it ignores the reality
that sometimes abortion is necessary
it's an important option for women to
have and it should not be something in
which the government is involved so on
so many levels this is a misguided
strategy so what's going to happen next
we saw it backfire at The Ballot Box in
part there's lots of things that we can
blame for what happened in November but
to a degree the position on abortion of
the Republican party was a factor so do
they stop talking about abortion that's
a problem because Republicans still
raise a disproportionate amount of money
from religious voters by saying we are
against abortion what do they do if they
don't talk about it there's a risk
talking about it the way they have
talked about it is also a risk so in
total the Republican party's position on
abortion is flawed
medically
it's flawed morally and ethically but
it's also flawed strategically if they
want to win elections and be successful
they're going to need to do a rethink I
don't know what that rethink should be I
don't care I don't want them to win so
it's not for me to start giving them
advice but we'll have to track and see
whether in some of the 2023 elections
abortion takes on a sort of different
tone from the Republican party and
certainly going into 2024. let me know
if you do have thoughts how should the
Republican Party straddle being against
abortion but the reality that
increasingly the country is in favor of
it Southwest Airlines had this massive
meltdown operational meltdown flights
canceled baggage lost people stranded at
airports in some cases arrested simply
trying to get rebooked and Fox News had
a segment
during which they tried to blame the
Secretary of Transportation in the Biden
Administration Pete bootage
um it's absolutely ridiculous Richard
Fowler who I know a little bit was on
this panel along with Titus or Tyrus and
some other people a number of different
experts as you can imagine and he said
it's completely absurd to blame mayor
Pete let's take a listen to this
discussion meantime just sleeping at an
airport for anyone who's ever done it
not a good time so I just it's such a
great program out there we have paid for
so many flights and bus trips for
illegals throughout this
um excellent point Tyrus Richard I'm
going to ask you a sincere question and
I'm not saying this to be here
are Democrats Democrats have a lot of
Hope in Pete Buda judge are they
embarrassed of just how he's performed
over the last couple years this is not
even about people to judge though let's
be very clearly no hold on 90 of the
flights that have been canceled in the
United States is from one Airline a
majority of the flights canceled around
the world is from one Airline so to sit
here and to blame this on the
transportation secretary when you have
one Airline and one era's Falls it's not
even the employees of this Airlines
ninety percent of the airline 90 of the
flights cancel the United States today
are from Southwest Airlines because you
have a bad management you have a they
have bad software you can't blame the
flight attendants you can't blame the
pilots you can't blame the ramp agents
you have to blame the people who sit in
the corporate Suites of Southwest
Airlines for canceling flights period
the end of story
the fact that Southwest can't manage
their friends it's ridiculous
could they get buses just like they do
for legal this is so crazy people I mean
I mean sure but once again this is a
this is about capitalism and an airline
that cannot manage it don't fly
Southwest Airlines good point all right
up next liberal Okay so
is anybody else noticing how these small
government conservatives all of a sudden
become socialists when a private company
is failing and saying hey the people
we've been accusing of being socialists
for years the Biden Administration
they're not being socialist enough or
even communist and just managing what
this private company is doing so the
real reason that this meltdown took
place was the Southwest Airlines
internal management system got
completely overwhelmed they have a
complicated model for assigning flights
they have an Antiquated internal system
for managing and Staffing those trips
and Company officials and union leaders
and experts are all in agreement about
that
first and foremost the Secretary of
Transportation oversees the entire
Transportation sector so that includes
Aviation
Maritime Transportation highways Rail
and they have other things that they do
as well okay it's a big picture position
the Department of Transportation and
Pete Budaj as the Secretary of
Transportation the idea that it's Buddha
judge's fault that one Airline had a
massive meltdown because of their own
Antiquated system or to try to hold Pete
bootage responsible it's completely and
totally pathetic now let's go beyond
that because you could say well the
context in which this happened
is the responsibility of the Department
of Transportation or something
uh just about all of the things that
affect individual Airlines actually have
nothing to do with the Department of
Transportation you've got weather
weather is like a category that affects
flights maintenance issues deferred
maintenance stacking up and accumulating
and creating a problem Staffing
shortages
um employees getting sick for example as
we saw during the covet pandemic
technical problems it has nothing to do
with the Secretary of Transportation at
all now if you had
some new government decree that limited
the ability of Airlines to I don't know
do whatever it is they need to do and
you could specifically point to it as a
policy affecting all Airlines I would
listen there's no doubt about it but
this is this is absolutely and
completely absurd Pete butterjudge is
not an operational manager the Secretary
of Transportation has nothing to do with
the internal dynamics of Airlines and
doesn't influence day-to-day operations
in any way and this is just an attempt
to criticize Joe Biden's Administration
that that's really all it is but maybe
even more interesting is the hypocrisy
here
this Republican party these right
Wingers on Fox very low information
Republic I mean they go for the lowest
hanging fruit because that's what Their
audience expects the Republican party
has long espoused the belief
that government regulation is
unnecessary and it's bad for business
too much involvement from the government
is bad it's not that it's neutral it's
actually bad we should leave the private
sector to operate without interference
in this case they immediately say it
must be the federal government's fault
we should blame Pete butterjudge because
of the operational delays of one Airline
even despite all of the complex factors
that are that are involved there it's
absurd and they are pathetic and
understand that that segment we just
watched they are calling for government
Intervention when they say
Peach should have done more
what they're saying is the government
should have gotten more involved in the
operations of a single private Airline
that's the opposite of what they
normally espouse so the hypocrisy is
galling and it shouldn't really surprise
us because they're more interested in
scoring political points particularly
With Their audience who seems to have
barely a clue what's going on I mean
this is not my opinion I'm not
editorializing you look at studies that
look at how informed are people who
primarily get their news from Outlet a b
c d the people who primarily get news
from Fox are of the least informed
people in one study people who get their
news from Fox are less informed than
people who don't even pay attention to
the news if you can believe that it's
unbelievable that's who this message is
tailored to
which ignores completely that they are
calling for the very thing which they
claim to oppose federal government
getting involved in the business of
Private Industry we'll have this clip on
our Instagram if you want to see it in
its full Glory you can find it by
searching Instagram for David packman
show you can also find me on Instagram
by searching for david.pakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
well this is an interesting turn of
events lying Republican Congressman
elect George Santos is now under
criminal investigation you've got to
love it you know that I was thinking
back to earlier this week when he first
addressed his lies
the thing he was hanging on to was I
haven't done anything criminal remember
this clip
I'm not a criminal not here not abroad
in any jurisdiction in the world have I
ever committed any crimes to get down to
the nitty-gritty I'm not a fraud I'm not
a a criminal who defrauded the entire
country and made up this fictitional
character well fictitional or fictitious
or whatever word you want to use it
turns out maybe there is some
criminality AP reports New York
representative elect Santos investigated
for lying about his past he is now under
investigation by Long Island prosecutors
after Revelation surfaced that he lied
about his Heritage his education and his
professional pedigree as he was
campaigning he has shown no signs of
stepping aside even as he publicly
admitted to a long list of Lies Nassau
County district attorney Ann Donnelly a
republican said the Fabrications and
inconsistencies were nothing short of
stunning saying quote the residents of
Nassau County and other parts of the
Third District must have an honest and
accountable representative in Congress
if a crime was committed in this County
we will prosecute it what would be so
remember lied about his employment
history lied about his educational
history lied about being Jewish
apparently told the truth about being
gay and later I'm going to tell you he
apparently lied about his mom dying in 9
11. we're going to get to that that's a
whole other sick ordeal so how could
this be a crime yes in a normal job
where you're not voted in if you lied in
this way to Human Resources you would be
fired you would be like oh but this is
different how could this be a crime in
this particular situation fraud is the
most likely charge so lying about one's
educational and employment history can
be considered fraud if it's done with
the intention of obtaining a job or
other benefits it's abundantly clear
because he said it in an interview
because of the elitist New York Times
not valuing his customer service
experience he almost had no choice but
to claim to have worked for Goldman
Sachs and graduated from a college he
didn't graduate from he was almost
forced into it so he's essentially
saying in order to get this job
in order to get the type of coverage I
need and to get voted in uh I
embellished as he calls it we call it
straight up lying that meets the
definition of Fraud lying in order to
obtain a job or other benefits and by
the way it's taxpayer dollars that go to
pay his salary and those benefits that's
the most likely charge now in other
situations lying about your education or
employment history if you do it under
oath you're talking about perjury right
if you do it in a court case could be
considered perjury and then could have
legal consequences discrimination if you
lie about your religion as he did and
then that is somehow used to
discriminate or gain an unfair advantage
in certain situations then it can be
against the law and then
misrepresentation if you lie about your
employment history or your educational
history if it's done with the intent of
misleading others it can lead to legal
consequences including find and
imprisonment whether that would be the
case in this particular situation I I
really can't say we're kind of getting
ahead of ourselves but there's one other
aspect to the possible criminality and
it relates to some campaign loans George
Santos's massive campaign loans may not
be legal reports The Daily Beast and
here's the deal with that
um there are he loaned his campaigns
seven hundred thousand dollars
it's not clear how he did it and as the
article says it uh it's been a bit of a
mystery
um but depending on how that was done
that also could actually be a violation
of campaign Finance law and uh the
article explains it in detail The Daily
Beast has part of an answer
um the identities of four of Santos's
corporate clients the Revelation puts
him in more hot water what he did with
the money he obtained could be even more
damning Santos has admitted using cash
from his company to fund his campaign
that could be an unlawful seven hundred
thousand dollar corporate contribution
that's because while candidates for
federal office may give unlimited
amounts of their own money to their
campaign they cannot expressly tap
corporate accounts to do so uh so that
also may be a criminal aspect to this
entire thing criminal is one part my
hope is that all of this gets him to
resign and say that he will not be
seated which is scheduled to happen next
week we're running out of time
Republicans maybe put Democrats plan to
object from what I'm reading Democrat
Democrats are going to object to his
being sworn in what that will lead to is
a vote on whether he should or shouldn't
be sworn in Republicans of course will
have the majority in in that new
Congress but it will put every single
one of them in a position of having to
vote Yes this liar fraudster should be
seated or not that could get very
interesting we'll know more about that
next week did George Santos lie about
his mom dying in 9 11. this is really
really sick stuff we're talking about
Republican Congressman elect George
Santos elected by the voters of New York
he lied about his employment history he
lied about his educational history he
lied about being Jewish he appears to
have lied about his grandparents being
refugees from the Holocaust he appears
to have lied about so many different
things he is now under criminal
investigation but here is an explosive
new claim
George said this is a mediaite report
George Santos alleged that the 9 11
attacks claimed his mother's life
and five months later said she died in
2016. 15.
years after the 9 11 attacks listen to
this yashar Ali flagged these tweets
from 2021 last night
these appear to be contradictory claims
to say the least
on July 12th of 2021 George Santos
tweeted 911 claimed my mother's life
9 11 claimed my mother's life
five months later in December of 2021
he said his mom died in December of 2016
which is
15 years and two months after 9 11.
December this is his tweet December 23rd
this year marks five years I lost my
best friend and Mentor mom you will live
forever in my heart
Santos campaign website States quote
George's mother was in her office in the
South Tower
on 9 11 2001 when the horrific events of
that day unfolded she survived the
tragic events on 9 11 but passed away a
few years later when she lost her battle
to cancer
anybody have any idea what's going on
here because I certainly don't and the
article writes although many at Ground
Zero in the aftermath developed health
problems like cancer
15 years is not a few years later
so what of this is true I have no idea
as a reminder media I reminds us Santos
also claimed he lost four employees in
the 2016 Pulse Nightclub shooting in
Orlando however none of the 49 people
killed are linked to any of the places
that he even claimed to have worked
which is a whole other story I don't
know what the truth is but it is natural
to be extraordinarily skeptical given
the disgusting nature of this guy's lies
now is he ultimately going to going to
be forced into resignation I don't know
we're running out of time
um I believe he should be he has shown a
willingness to lie for what he believes
to be personal gain but also even if you
want to argue or suggest that there are
other motivations like for example he's
just a pathological liar there are
people who it's almost reflexive they
just lie they lie they lie they lie you
know I I I've told a couple stories I
was reminded of another person I know
where it it was like a reflex it was
quite literally a reflex and I remember
having a conversation with them where I
said oh yeah you know um like at the
time we were I think we were using
Constant Contact for email where I go
yeah we um we use a service called
Constant Contact for email they're
actually uh
um you know they're pretty good or
something and the person said oh yeah my
uncle works at Constant Contact and I
said oh really because Constant Contact
space like in the Boston suburbs I
didn't know you had a you're like oh no
well yeah he works remotely for them oh
huh it wasn't true just just it's
natural natural instinct to just lie lie
lie if that's part of what is going on
here with George Santos that also
doesn't make no particularly good
candidate to be a member of the House of
Representatives so we'll see what
happens in the next couple days the
pressure to resign is mounting uh the
criminal probe is a real problem at this
point and that may be what pushes him
over the edge into resignation but at
the same time
he may be one of 435 members of Congress
starting next week which would be yet
another embarrassment and humiliation
for the United States not to the degree
of trump being president certainly but
it will certainly be a humiliation we're
going to try to get him on the show
I would love for him to tell us in his
own words what all of this is about I
don't know that he's going to accept
that invitation
if you value what we do at the David
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show well as
you know there are often not that many
things that Democrats are doing
correctly for themselves and sometimes
Democrats are sort of relying on or
hoping that Republicans will mess
themselves up it's not a great strategy
but to the extent that it's useful you
do love to see it and the latest is that
Marjorie Taylor green the repugnant and
radical republican congresswoman from
Georgia is furious that Tulsi gabbard
hammered Republican Congressman elect
liar George Santos on Fox News two
nights ago so let me remind you what
happened George Santos is a huge liar
lied about his job history lied about
his educational history lied about being
Jewish maybe lied about the
circumstances of his mother's death lie
lie lie lie lie
he appeared with Tulsi gabbard who used
to be a Democrat now she's not next
thing you know Tulsi gabbard's
campaigning for Kerry Lake and Herschel
Walker and filling in for Tucker Carlson
but to her credit Tulsi did a good job
to some degree of holding George Santos
accountable Marjorie Taylor green did
not like it unleashing a fascinating
series of tweets
insofar as it tells us a lot about how
these people think about politics let's
look at the Tweet thread this is again
Marjorie Taylor green not happy with
Tulsi quote Tulsi gabbard who says she
is a former Democrat gave representative
elect George Santos zero Grace while
George is admitting and apologizing for
lying about his resume just like her
former colleagues are giving George zero
Grace and even demanding he resigned
remember he didn't admit and apologize
he minimized called them embellishments
said the explanation would go over the
voters heads because they couldn't
possibly understand it and on and on and
on to say it was an apology is a little
bit much
okay Marjorie continuing quote Tulsi
says that George's actions on the house
floor are what is most important but
George has not even had the chance to
take action for his district on the
house floor because he isn't even sworn
in yet Tulsi also says how can his
district believe anything he says when
he is standing on the house floor
fighting for them that's a good question
I too believe actions and words are
extremely important but I don't think a
former Democrat Whose actions on the
house floor as recent as 2020 that gave
her an a from Planned Parenthood and F
from the NRA and introduced the climate
agenda signature piece of legislation
called The Off act designed to end all
fossil fuels the same as aoc's green New
Deal should lecture a newly elected
Republican member of Congress on how he
should vote to represent his Republican
district oh boy
um Marjorie continuing this tirade quote
I do appreciate that Tulsi says words
that sound conservative now even though
she can't take action to back them up I
am glad she like George realized she
made mistakes and was wrong every time
she voted to support killing The Unborn
taking away our gun rights and
legislated to kill America's energy
Independence and the fossil fuel
industry I hoped we'll see a sincere
just like I hope George is sincere I
think we Republicans should give George
Santos a chance and see how he
legislates and votes not treat him the
same as the left is listen there is not
even the smallest doubt
that were George Santos a Democrat
Marjorie Taylor green and all of these
people would be treating him completely
differently and to some degree although
I'm not a fan of Tulsi gabbards she
seems to be treating him the way he
deserves to be treated based on his
actions not because of his party
designation similarly
I hope you all know
that my position on George Santos would
be exactly the same if he were a
Democrat and as you all know this idea
that there's a double standard among
everybody when it comes to these wrong
these types of wrongdoing is very much
untrue I don't know anyone on the left
who was defending Anthony Weiner when he
was involved in sexting minors and
whatever all the different things that
he did when that Democratic Congressman
I believe it was was caught with 10
grand in his freezer I didn't defend him
I don't know anybody that did it is not
all the same and while Marjorie Taylor
green wants to claim
that it is the left with the double
standard it is really her ilk the Maga
people
Etc the only
really good take here from Marjorie
Taylor green like I would if you said to
me David sir what would be an
intellectually honest reaction from
Marjorie Taylor green that defends
George Santos it would be if Marjorie
Taylor green came forward and said
listen
let's not be hard on George Santos
because at the end of the day our entire
party really is as dishonest as he is
like when we say cutting taxes for the
rich is good for the economy that's just
as dishonest and more damaging than when
he said he graduated from college that
would be a surprisingly refreshing
accurate uh take from Marjorie Taylor
green not the argument she's making
Marjorie Taylor green as is almost
always the case coming up with the worst
take on every issue a constant liar a
consistent liar and she lacks total
morals values and ethics and that's part
of why she has no problem with the lies
told by George Santos I don't hate the
infighting you all know that I think
it's good for the left the left needs
help any help the left can get I think
we should take assuming we're not doing
anything illegal or immoral and
certainly letting them fight amongst
themselves uh has nothing immoral or
illegal to it
failed Arizona
Republican gubernatorial candidate Kerry
lake is panicking and deleting tweets
this when I imagine someone deleting
tweets even if they're doing it on their
phone I imagine them feverishly typing
on a keyboard but that may not be the
case she is panicking and deleting
tweets attacking a judge after sanctions
have been demanded so let's back it up
and kind of explain all of it uh Carey
Lake lost the Arizona gubernatorial
election and what I mean by lost is her
opponent Katie Hobbs got more votes
because more people voted for Katie
Hobbs which means Katie Hobbs will be
the governor very simple and yet so
complicated okay she won Kerry Lake lost
Carrie like sues claiming really she won
her lawsuit was thrown out
and now she's just getting herself into
more and more and more trouble the hill
reports Lake deletes tweet targeting
Maricopa judge after officials seek
sanctions defeated Arizona gubernatorial
candidate Kerry Lake deleted a tweet
accusing the judge who dismissed her
election challenge of Integrity
violations the Tweet posted early Monday
suggested the founding partner of a law
firm representing Katie Hobbs emailed
Maricopa County superior court judge
Peter Thompson what to say as he
authored the dismissal that's an
extremely serious charge to make against
the judge that someone wrote to him and
said
here's your marching orders here's what
decision you will make in court
uh quote the dismissal of Kerry Lake's
election lawsuit shows voter
disenfranchisement no longer matters
um this is her tweet legal experts
believe his decision was Ghost written
they suspect top left-wing attorneys
like Mark Elias emailed him what to say
Maricopa County and Hobbes in their
capacities as Secretary of State and
governor-elect cited the tweet in asking
the judge to impose sanctions on Lake as
well as on her attorneys arguing that
Lakes Lakes campaign's broader election
challenge was groundless and constituted
harassment so what is it that is going
on here she is an annoyance yes but she
is an annoyance to a degree that may
actually deserve legal sanctions and so
she's panicking and so now she's
deleting the Tweet now as much as I
would love to see serious sanctions
against Carrie Lake you know the Wright
loves to talk about frivolous lawsuits
oh the coffee was too hot turns out that
was actually a lawsuit that had some
Merit if you actually learn about it oh
someone said Merry Christmas to me and
I'm offended I don't know of any lawsuit
like that but this is the caricature of
the right and the so-called frivolous
lawsuits they believe the left is
engaged in even though we have many
systems in place to dismiss frivolous
lawsuits but it is actually they who
have no hesitation they have no qualms
whatsoever
um gumming up the legal system after
2020 with more than 60 different
complaints in all sorts of different
jurisdictions for nothing for nothing
Trump lost that's all that happened and
similarly Carrie Lake raising money
filing lawsuits hiring lawyers bringing
in experts taking up court time for
something that is obviously meritless
and is of course going absolutely
nowhere and now they're panicking that
they might be sanctioned if there is any
good news for Kerry Lake and this sort
of bugs me but it is what's going on
it's not really clear that she is going
to face those sanctions uh Fox news
reports Arizona judge denies requests
for sanctions against Lake and rewards a
33 thousand dollar reimbursement
an Arizona judge denied a request from
governor-elect Katie Hobbs seeking
sanctions against Kerry Lake though the
sanctions were denied the judge did
award Hobbes a little more than 33
thousand dollars to cover costs
associated with retaining expert
Witnesses during a two-day trial brought
on by Lake challenging those results
Lake lost her bid by half a percentage
Point etc etc okay so at least in this
first finding a judge is not issuing
sanctions against Kerry Lake
um what you have to understand here
is that there is a mishmash of political
stuff for lack of that's a technical
term going on in Arizona which includes
right thinking and clear-minded people
who see the entire Cary Lake Fiasco for
what it is terrible candidate lost
panicked is embarrassed and is trying to
sue anyone she can
but you also see some judges in Arizona
that are running a little bit of
interference for Kerry Lake saying
listen
we believe she sincerely believed that
she won and if Kerry Lake sincerely
believed she won
then most of her actions are acceptable
in the eyes of the law it's sort of like
covering for a toddler's temper tantrum
arguing this particular one was
justified and thus everything they did
in all of the sequel a that resulted
from that tantrum uh are okay and we
shouldn't be too harsh as a result
how can someone like Carrie Lake be
considered a good candidate to lead
anything in government whether it's it
being the administrator of a state like
Arizona or whatever when she can't even
control her own impulses on Twitter such
that they start getting her into
potential legal trouble and then she has
to run and delete the tweets but it
doesn't really matter that's really been
Republicans for the last six years who
are the worst people we could possibly
find to do the jobs that are needed
let's make them our nominees
um many of my lawyer friends especially
those that do criminal defense say that
it is really really common that their
clients just can't stop talking or they
won't stop talking either to the media
or recently in the modern era more often
social media posts and to some degree
that seems to be what's going on here
with Kerry Lake let's hope she does face
sanctions let's hope her attorneys do as
well
we have a voicemail number it is
available 24 hours a day and many of you
do call at 2 3 4 5 in the morning here
is a call I got which actually brings up
a really interesting issue which is why
did it take this long to find out that
George Santos was lying about just about
everything and this is an important
question take a listen
hello David this is Aaron Cooper I had a
quick thought about George Santos and
his lies
I'm wondering why his opponent Thomas
did not uncover all these Librarians
campaigns and I'm thinking the reason
why is because he ran for governor and
lost in the Democratic primary and I
think after he just lost motivation he
wasn't that interested in winning the
New York District just want to get your
thoughts thank you bye listen this is a
very good question
the George Santos lies
they could have been uncovered by his
opponent's opposition research they
could have been uncovered earlier we're
talking by investigative journalists but
they were not now I don't know enough
about the Dynamics to blame anyone in
particular but as a general principle
when you have a guy that it's not just
one lie it's not oh you know I used to
be a city councilor and I passed an
ordinance and then we research it and oh
you didn't pass that ordinance this was
lied about employment history lied about
educational history lied about ethnic
background religious background call it
what you want potentially lied about his
mom's death as a result of 9 11
definitely lied about having four
employees die in the Pulse Nightclub
shooting in 2016. I mean lie upon libon
claimed he claimed he owned property and
sold a property but now says oh I never
claim to own property I can't give you
all the lies that he told
it is a failure
and maybe it remains to be seen who
failed that neither investigative
journalism nor opposition research
turned up the fact that this guy was
making it all up and uh maybe it will be
an instructive example for the future
but I think that that's a very good
point on today's bonus show we are going
to start with what is genuinely a sad
story friend of the show Jamie Raskin
Democratic congressman who I think would
be a great candidate for president
has announced that he has cancer and he
says it is serious but treatable and
that he expects to make a full recovery
we're going to talk about it we will
also talk about an incident in which a
terminally ill patient in a hospital was
vaping cannabis and police were called
and it escalated very quickly and in
France they have passed the law Banning
single-use tableware meaning disposable
forks and knives at fast food
restaurants what is the size of that
carbon footprint how much of a different
will it make is it practical do people
like it are they Furious very
interesting decision in France all of
those stories and more wait we're David
sir where are these stories they're on
the bonus show today oh the bonus show
where you and make money yeah everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad that's right memberships which
include access to the bonus show fund
staff salaries benefits Health Care
connectivity equipment legal we need a
lot of legal folks
Etc you can sign up at joinpakman.com
you'll get instant access to the bonus
show
you'll get the commercial free audio and
video streams of the show and you will
be invited to our members only Town
Halls all of that and more sign up at
joinpakman.com I'll see you then and
then we will be back tomorrow with the
final episode of 2026. sorry of 2022.
we'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors please donate to
give directly the non-profit letting you
send cash directly to the world's
poorest families when you donate to give
directly.org Pacman a generous donor
will match your donations up to fifteen
thousand dollars makes a perfect holiday
gift help us reach fifteen thousand
dollars by the end of the year using the
link below